hola a todos hoy vamos a ver cómo los
padres de familia también pueden usar
khan academy para acompañar el
aprendizaje de sus hijos lo primero que
tienen que hacer es crear una cuenta
como padres y para eso van donde dice
regístrate en la esquina derecha
y eligen la opción de padres
y ponen el correo electrónico con el que
se van a crear una cuenta
vamos a poner puede ser su correo
personal
una contraseña
de más de 8 caracteres y con algún
número y le dan clic a regístrate
esta es la página principal de los
padres y lo primero que hace es khan
academy es darle la bienvenida
[Música]
y los invita a explorar la plataforma
como papás
vamos a ponerle
que hemos entendido lo primero que
invita a khan academy es a conectarte
con tu hijo
y esto quiere decir que si su hijo ya
tiene una cuenta en khan academy puede
el papá también hacerle seguimiento a lo
que el maestro le ha ido dejando de
tareas y cómo va a ir avanzando entonces
por ejemplo vamos a darle clic aquí a
agregar a tu hijo
acá hay que poner primero la edad del
hijo
o si tu hijo ya tiene una cuenta por
ejemplo vamos a ponerle click aquí en mi
hijo ya tiene una cuenta y ponemos el
correo electrónico de su hijo
vamos a poner a siguiente
y la invitación ya fue enviada a mi hijo
y ya podremos ver todo podrás seguir el
progreso de mis hijos en khan academy
ahora vamos a poner
para volver a la vista de la página
principal del padre
un segundo paso que sugiere khan academy
es siete consejos para ayudar a tu hijo
a tener éxito y aquí nos presenta un
artículo
en el que nos da algunas pistas de cómo
poder acompañar a nuestros hijos a usar
khan academy alentándolos a seguir
aprendiendo
uno de ellos bueno para los padres es
monitorear el progreso de su hijo
celebrar los éxitos y logros y aprender
sobre los retos establecer objetivos y
metas juntos recompensar también a sus
hijos por las metas darles el ejemplo
aprendiendo algo nuevo hablar con los
profesores de su hijo y bueno hacer de
khan academy una entidad familiar sea
justamente lo que se busca
nuevamente si vamos a la página
principal como padre luego también le
inviste el papá va a hacer uso de la
plataforma y seguir aprendiendo porque
como han podido ver hay muchos temas
inclusive los padres pueden reforzar
para ayudar a sus hijos por ejemplo con
las áreas o temas que ellos mismos
quieran aprender
y luego ya le invitan como último paso a
que su hijo inicie la sesión y comienza
a usar caracas esta es una forma muy
sencilla como los papás también pueden
estar involucrados en el aprendizaje de
sus hijos
usando canaca de una vez que ya
agregamos a nuestros hijos y ellos
aceptaron la solicitud ellos comenzarán
a usar khan academy con solos o con sus
maestros y los padres en la parte
inferior de su panel podrán ver el
progreso de sus hijos por ejemplo en
este caso vemos que la hija que en este
caso es maría pérez solo usado por un
minuto en los últimos siete días la
plataforma y podemos ver que necesita
práctica todavía en la habilidad de
multiplicar números negativos y ha
podido ver dos vídeos que aparecen aquí
es así como el papá puede hacer
seguimiento muy detallado a lo que están
haciendo sus hijos y cómo van
progresando esos